Now before we can actually utilize groom inside of any unreal engine of five projects
There are a few things that we need to enable including some project settings as well as a plug-in
So first we need to make sure that in our project settings under rendering we have support compute skin cache
enabled now if you are in
5.6 or later this is actually enabled for you by default
Because it is enabled when ray tracing is enabled now again, let's go ahead and check to make sure so here we go
I have a five dot six version of the third-person template here, so we're going to go up to edit
Project settings, and then we're going to look down for our rendering here
Rendering there we go
And then we are going to look for our setting here
And I'm just going to actually type this in so that's you PP or T support
And there we go we have our support compute skin cache, which is enabled
And the other thing that we need to do here is we are going to go next to our plugins
And then under geometry we're going to enable the olympic groom importer
Which allows us to actually import grooms, and then we're going to make sure that groom is enabled
This is going to allow the rendering and simulation, so let's pop back over to the editor now so again
We're going to go to edit
plugins, and then we're going to look for our geometry and
Geometry there we go
we're going to make sure that our olympic groom importer is on and
Then also make sure that groom itself is enabled now remember as with all of our plugins or our engine settings
And project settings we are going to need to restart the editor once we have done that
So I'm going to go ahead and click the restart which I want everybody to do now and once we come back
We will talk about importing groom assets